oder nicht, das muss ich noch rausstellen
erstmal mal ein bisschen streamrichtig, honest
hausechampchampchamp
hä? warum bin ich angeblich schon ne stunde on? ach ne, das ist ne minute, lul
kack noob, keine urzeiten lesen, keine timer besser gesagt
Leute, ich hab neue sponsoring anfragen gekriegt, ihr glaubt nicht von wem
nein, das ist nicht raid shadow legends, weil es ja noch gar keiner da, weil das stream noch
nicht richtig on ist, aber wie gesagt, es ist nicht raid shadow legends, ihr könnt ja mal raten
gleich, oder ihr könnt schon mal raten für die die da sind, ganz zwei leute die da sind, lul
gucken, gucken bis twitch das ganze kapiert, dass das stream on ist
ah jetzt, jetzt klappt das langsam, oder? ja jetzt hat jetzt hat twitch gecheckt, dass der stream on ist
Leute, ratet mal wer mir eine sponsoring anfrage geschickt hat
und nein es ist nicht raid shadow legends, lustigerweise was was ich mir schon lange mal
angucken wollte wieder, nein, nein, nein, kein vpn, wobei es ist gar nicht so weit von vpn entfernt
die haben auch sowas
es ist kein es ist kein nord vpn und kein express vpn und kein süd vpn und was es sonst noch alles gibt
nein das ist opera gx und da fällt mir mal wieder ein ich habe ganz lange kein opera gx mehr
ausprobiert sagt opera gx immer noch oder gibt es mittlerweile einen grund warum man das verwenden
sollte benutzt es jemand von euch also gibt es irgendeinen grund warum also weshalb man
opera gx verwenden sollte außer außer dass die einen mit sehr viel werbe budget gbaton wollen
dazu ja das ist der gaming ja das braucht doch kein mensch das ist das ist ein feature das
verstehe ich nicht warum man das braucht ich meine es gibt die möglichkeit entweder hat man genug
ram ja und ich würde es wundern wenn chrome nicht auch in aktive tabs suspended und und wenn man
tatsächlich im hintergrund irgendwas laufen hat was viel leistung zieht da kann man einfach
zumachen während man spielt weil das zieht ja auch nicht weniger leistungen dadurch dass man
es irgendwie limitiert wenn es eine leistung braucht also ich verstehe den sinn von ram und
cpu begrenzer nicht die haben in den briefing geschickt die haben in den briefing geschickt ich
habe mir sogar kurz überlegt ob ich das nicht machen soll und ich war schon kurz davor zu
zu sagen über preis war auch ok und dann haben die mir den briefing geschickt wo drin stand was
ich alles machen soll und da muss ich sagen aber mein jetzt muss ich ein bisschen laut ja also das
war ein bisschen zu wie soll ich sagen so umfangreich und ja kannst du vorstellen dass
denn wobei pewdiepie kann sagen was er will der ist so groß also das briefing war soll ich sagen
so ein bisschen grenzwertig irgendwie weil es ist ein grund ja es ist ein grund also es ist ein
ding zu sagen so nach dem motto ich bin von was überzeugt so ich werde von hetzner gesponsert
by the way ausrufe zeichen hetzner im chat da bin ich auch überzeugt von das benutze ich auch selbst ok und
die alte andere alternative ist wenn ich was vielleicht ganz ok finde aber jetzt nicht
herausragend geil dann sage ich natürlich auch nicht so meine persönliche empfehlung ich benutze
schon seit jahren ist der beste browser überhaupt das würde ich ja dann nicht sagen ich würde dann
halt sagen dass man ist klar im kontext dieses placements erkennt dass das halt das ist halt so
wie keine ahnung wie wenn irgendein fußballspieler wärmung macht für ratio farmen oder so wenn der
sagt ratio farmen meine kopf wir sind wie weggeblasen dann weiß auch jeder okay der erzählt das weil
irgendein werbetexter gesagt hat ratio farmen einen kopf wir sind wie weg weggeblasen so und
deswegen muss das für mich erkennbar sein und die wollten halt dass das quasi gebatet
als wäre ich persönlich davon halt mega überzeugt und und da waren dann auch so
dinge drin wie dass ich faken sollte dass andere browser schlecht sind wohingegen opera gx gut ist
und sowas so nach dem motto starte ein spiel und zeige wie es laggt und dann macht opera
gx auf und es läuft flüssig so nach dem motto das war wirklich schon hart an der hat an der
g bade grenze also das habe ich nicht gemacht hätten die hätten die das nicht ganz so krass geschrieben und
oder oder alternativ ich habe wirklich persönlich voll krass überzeugt von dem browser ok dann
hätte ich wahrscheinlich gemacht weil mal ist mein mikrofon zu laut ich schrei einfach nur mega rum
kann es sein ne ist eigentlich alles wie immer
wie viel näher gut also ich darf das eigentlich sagen aber ich weiß nicht ob ich das sagen will
nee ich sage das nicht muss ja mal gedanken drüber machen niedrig vierstellig auf jeden
fall so viel kann ich sagen also wirklich niedrig vierstellig hast du schon mal was von windows
arme gehört was ach ach hier ja ok das haben wir doch sogar mal ausprobiert ist das nicht
dieses komische windows von diesem tuning von diesem tuning channel auf youtube
das ist doch das ist auch dieses die plotet windows das das haben wir uns doch mal im stream
angeguckt und ich musste alle fünf minuten keck wehen über irgendwelche blödsinnigen
sachen ne ne ne ne das das da halt da halte ich persönlich gar nichts von von solchen
geschichten ich wüsste auch gar nicht wozu man es braucht wenn ich ehrlich bin die videos sind leise
die videos bei mir können überhaupt nicht leise sein meine videos sind bloß nicht kompressort
bis zum geht nicht mehr wenn du die arme die lautstärken anguckst sind die eigentlich da
ist nicht so viel wie sagt wie sagt der audio der audio techniker headroom vorhanden mehr
ja das kommt ja dabei oder kommst du da kommst du nirgends wo drum herum dass du es
versteuern musst ach ja was wir heute machen was wir heute machen ist ganz einfach wir machen heute
postchamp ich habe mir überlegt ob wir nicht mal wieder stellenanzeigen gucken sollen habe
ich überlegt aber nicht ein bisschen keck wie es das service weiter basteln habe ich überlegt
wenn ich noch ein bisschen bettel viel spielen also aber ich habe mir gedacht es 20 15 es hat
keinen sinn da jetzt irgendwie großartig noch was zu machen wir machen jetzt gar nichts ich habe
übrigens weiter aufgeräumt das heißt wir können demnächst wahrscheinlich mal wieder einen das
heißt wieder der letzte stream war es ja schon wieder ja einen wieder auf mit max treten machen
ich habe hier also ich habe hier genau 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 kisten teilweise auch relativ große
kisten mit sachen drin da machen wir wieder auf aufräumen mit max ganz schön hast du die
amerikanische flagge von einem desktop entfernt habe ich eine amerikanische flagge tatsächlich
kakona warum habe ich warum habe ich nami flagge bei mir auf dem desktop ich weiß es nicht aber
wichtig ich habe so guck mal ich habe auch ich habe auch was französisches auf auf dem desktop
garten stellst ne das ist grad ziemlich langweilig da irgendwas zu stellen im garten stimmt das
sollten wir uns das die leute haben gemeint soll ich mir mal angucken können wir uns nachher
angucken leute ich habe ich habe ungelogen gestern das beste youtube video gesehen was ich je geguckt
habe also von kreativität her von der story her wie es zusammengeschnitten ist und ihr werdet
nicht glauben was meint ihr welches game das war weil vielleicht ist bestes youtube video aller
zeiten übertrieben aber wirklich ein finde ich wirklich gut gemachtes video und nicht so 08 15
scheiß ich man reagiert auf irgendwas wirklich ernsthaft ernsthaft jetzt ja mein kraft richtig
es war ein mein kraft video es war ein mein kraft video ich weiß gar nicht ob ich das so
kurz gucken ob ich das wieder finde ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher mal wie der titel war der
titel war irgendwas in die richtung von mein kraft server war oder irgendwie sowas 200 spieler
wartet mal ich gucke ob ich das das finde mein kraft layer civilization war es das
das war es nicht aber sowas in der richtung war das das da ne moment er reagiert aber auf
das richtige video seck moment der reagiert auf das video was ich meine original video ja das
meine ich ohne scheiß ich habe nie großartig mein kraft videos geguckt aber das fand ich
wirklich extrem gut gemacht wahrscheinlich ist da einiges gestellt gewesen aber story insgesamt
wie es geschnitten war vom soundtrack kreative idee das sogar spannend gewesen bis zum schluss
was rauskommt wirklich richtig gut gemacht das video hätte ich nie gedacht dass ich mal
sache hier das mein kraft video so eins der besten ich gesehen habe ich gucke ja normalerweise nie
mein kraft wo sind deine dislikes ah sekunde sekunde die dislikes return youtube dislikes
seck add to chrome add extension 600.000 plus user sieht man mal dass eindeutig das zum
besten der user war das zu entfernen und schon mal wieder dislikes so muss das sein dazu sage
ich nur youtube die ziehen das aber auch voll durch auf youtube das letzte creator update
youtube creator update haben wir vor ein paar tagen ja auch ganz jeder typ wünscht den schon sehen ach du
scheiße laden die da viel hoch monka ist ich kenne die videos nur weil die immer bei mir im
dashboard empfohlen werden zumindest im letzten creator update haben über was ganz was anderes
gesprochen und die ganzen comments unter youtube youtube sagt youtube was weiß ich irgendwelche
beleidigungen bring dislikes back dislikes bla hier remove dislikes also ich glaube youtube
hat sich den aufschrei kleiner vorgestellt aber das dumme ist halt youtube sitzt eindeutig am
längeren hebel du kannst da nichts dagegen machen also haben die nicht jetzt irgendwie ein sicht
aus stonks gründen was ich aber nicht glaube weil ich glaube letztendlich ist der move für
youtube kalkuliert dass es mehr geld bringt mit dem entfernen dislikes nicht wirklich für den
für den für den user die plattform besser zu machen also die sagen ja immer das ist so ein
generelles gelaber also es machen viele unternehmen so nachdem und wir machen alles für den user
der user ist bei uns quasi steht im mittelpunkt das ist alles schwachsinn was im mittelpunkt steht
ist dass es dem user gut genug geht beziehungsweise user genug anreize hat geld auszugeben und in dem
fall ist es halt so wenn leute dank deaktivieren der dislikes länger youtube videos gucken bringt
das unter dem strich mehr views und mehr geld für youtube und dass youtube nun wirklich irgendwelche
kleinen creator damit beschützen will das hat glaube ich keiner gefressen niemand glaubt das
niemand normalerweise hast du bei solchen sachen wenigstens so die obligatorischen leute in den
comments die immer wir können aber kurz die kommens reingucken falls sie die falls sie die
kommens nicht deaktiviert haben wir gucken wir gucken aber kurz rein ja ist das ist es dass
der dislike haben sie einen anderen typ hingestellt als sonst ich weiß nicht warum sie den hingestellt
haben wahrscheinlich dass man nicht so viel negatives mit den anderen verbinden so du
normalerweise hast du in den kommentaren so die obligatorischen leute die dann quasi immer rum
wie nennt man das rumschleim so corporate white nights weiß ich nicht wie man das nennt gescheit
die hast du immer die obligatorischen typen die gibt's eigentlich unter jedem video wenn so was
gerade ja ich glaube youtube so nach dem motto ist ein ganz großes problem die kleinen creator die
werden ja so hart gedisst immer die hast du immer und die hast du unter diesem video eigentlich so
gut wie gar nicht die hast du wie gesagt normalerweise hast du die immer aber hier
nicht also es hat wirklich niemand youtube abgekauft dass die das machen wegen dem was sie sagen dass
sie die kleinen creator beschützen wollen das ist einfach schwachsinn und das weiß youtube das
wissen die leute auch die leute sind zwar dumm aber so dumm sind die leute auch nicht ja natürlich
guckt mal habt ihr das gesehen ubisoft sekunde ich zeige euch mal wofür das gemacht ist mit
dem dislikes entfernen ubisoft nft ach die haben den offiziellen trailer gar nicht gezeigt oder
was ok ubisoft ich brauche ubisoft channel gib gib ubisoft channel ja na ist auch ok
haben die das
quads announcement haben die das gelöscht oder was ah das ist anlistet ahja guck mal
das ist ja ein voll beliebtes video 100.000 aufrufe 1000 likes das müssen ja die leute
voll abfeiern natürlich jeder der so ein bisschen bei verstand ist der weiß dass 1000
likes für 138.000 aufrufe im verhältnis vielleicht nicht so wahnsinnig gut sind allerdings könnte es
durchaus sein dass dieses werbung dieses video als werbung geschaltet wird zum beispiel von der
länge her wirds passen und werbe videos haben auch so gut wie nie likes und dislikes weil die
leute sich nicht die mühe machen da drauf zu gehen so und jetzt gucken wir uns das mal mit
dem plugin an was dislikes wieder aktiviert und siehe da das video hat 21.000 dislikes
ja jetzt wissen wir auch sofort für wen unter anderem ich will jetzt nicht sagen sie haben das
für ubisoft gemacht dass sie schwach sind aber für welche klientel youtube die dislikes entfernt
hat ein scheiß haben die die dislikes entfernt um kleine creator zu beschützen es war von
anfang an anlistet ich habe das gestern angeguckt man hat 600 dislikes gehabt da war es auch schon
anlistet habe ich jetzt gar nicht mehr dran gedacht ein scheiß haben die das gemacht um
kleine creator zu beschützen das ist einfach nur vorgeschrubben gewesen dass man nicht dass
man nicht so viel sagen kann so nach dem motto sobald du was sagst bist du dafür dass kleine
creator harassed werden was ja schwachsinnig ist es gibt andere möglichkeiten zumindest kann nicht
der weißheit letzter schluss ein eines der zentralen bestandteile dieser plattform zu entfernen das
kennt man ja auch aus anderen bereichen dann werden immer quasi so todschlag argumente vor
vorgebracht so nach dem motto ja wir brauchen vorrats datenspeicherung wegen kinderpornos wir
brauchen vorrats wegen morden wir brauchen vorrats datenspeicherung wegen ganz ganz furchtbar
kriminellen geschichten und am ende ein paar jahre später kommt da so ein scheiß wie die
redtube abmahnwelle oder sowas was nichts aber auch gar nichts mit dem ganzen kram zu tun hat
bloß sich wieder irgendwelche leute bereichern wollten es wird immer irgendwas vorgeschoben
dass der aufschrei nicht so groß ist und in dem fall beim dislike entfernen was halt wir
wollen kleine creator beschützen zumindest das ding kommt nicht gut an
excellent übrigens danke für die subscriptions joho und sandor 385 joho 27 bitteschön hab ich
nicht gesehen so und ja es hat keinen sinn sich da drüber aus sondern youtube sitzt da beim
endeffekt am längeren hebel wenn youtube sieht dass es dadurch mehr geld macht wird es auch so
bleiben youtube wird es nur ändern wenn ihm die leute wegrennen das problem ist youtube brennen
die leute nicht weg weil wohin sollen sie denn klipp fisch was gibt es denn so odyssey oder sowas
gibt es noch aber das ist auch nicht so wirklich das ist auch sehr nische alles ja was gibt es
klipp fisch überhaupt noch zack muss mal kurz checken ich glaube da ich glaube ich traue mich
nicht auf die seite drauf zu gehen klipp fisch gibt es klipp fisch noch klipp fisch ist weg
zwar auch reines der sinnlosesten ich kann mich noch an klipp fisch erinnern immer wenn man auf
klipp fisch auf die seite gegangen ist wie war denn wie war denn die adresse von klipp fisch war das
war das klipp fisch.de komm mal archiv da habe ich kann ich mich noch internet archiv kann ich mich
noch dran erinnern immer wenn man auf klipp fisch gegangen ist dann war da so eine die die
zunge rausgestreckt hat dass das das bild das fand ich damals also immer noch übelst eklig
dieses thumbnail das hat sich bei mir so eingebrannt das verbinde ich irgendwie mit klipp fisch
war ja auch nicht wie ich da drauf komme so hier klipp fisch 2010 jawoll klipp fisch 2010 beste
hallo ah so sah klipp fisch aus lustige videos gratis fun ach du scheiße welches ist das der
asitoni nee das ist nicht der asitoni das war big brother ein bisschen so ein bisschen so ein
bisschen an asitoni erinnert guck mal ich meine das war schon der gleiche shit wie jetzt teilweise
auf youtube am start ist aber ich weiß ich kann verstehen dass es keiner haben wollte klipp fisch
asitoni mein video ist noch da wisst ihr warum ich vorher ich weiß dass wir mehr noch da ist
letztens bei mir auf der arbeit gab es eine veranstaltung die wurde dann im intranet
geschert ein link zum livestream der veranstaltung und natürlich was war das erste was ich gemacht
habe ich bin in die browser tools und hat mir natürlich mal den link in link angeguckt über
welches streaming portal das läuft und was war es wie meo das war das erste mal dass ich
seit langem wieder festgestellt habe wie meo gibt es noch ist eigentlich ich erzähle ja ab und zu
immer mal so ein bisschen real life stellts so ein bisschen bisschen kram aber insgesamt werde
ich ich werde wieder den stellenanzeigen video machen demnächst meine kopfstütze ist irgendwie
runtergefallen das ist bei businessfilm beliebt ja anscheinend aber ich werde jetzt kein hier
krasse elo tricks ich flanke 20 weiberberg real life stories machen also erstens habe
ich keine real life stories in dieser richtung die ich erzählen könnte und außerdem würde ich
so real life stories auch nicht erzählen gibt ja noch mehr traingen soll ich wollte ganz
einfach sagen danke für den sub aber ist gar kein sub oder ist das sub weiß ich nicht steht nicht da
naja gut habe ich jetzt irgendwas übersehen hier leute questions oder so ne tja die frage ist was
machen wir heute die antworte ist wir machen nichts wir machen postchamp ich laber ein bisschen vor
mich hin wenn irgendwas wissen wollt könnt ihr was ins chat schreiben ansonsten schwätze ich so ein
bisschen bisschen vor mich hin weil ich sonst nichts zu tun habe es ist halo release gerade den gesehen
halo infinite release vor einer stunde und das problem ist nur was bei den timeouts geht das
sind leute die sich absichtlich einen timeout einfangen weil sie der meinung sind sie haben
einen timeout verdient ich habe auch keine ahnung warum man als channel points belohnung
einen timeout einlöst aber gut ich will ja nicht sagen wenn die leute das wollen dann kriegen sie
timeouts also halo infinite kam ja raus vor einer stunde gab schon wieder ein bisschen mini shitstorm
weil die kampagne so spät anlockt ist und ich habe aber einen fehler gemacht kann man eigentlich
gar nicht sagen ich habe mir die komplette story angeguckt schon ich muss die kampagne nicht
spielen weil ich habe gar keinen bock die kampagne zu spielen weil die story ist scheiße und ich hab
keinen bock auf open world also kann ich mir das mit der kampagne einfach sparen ansonsten wollte
ich heute eigentlich die halo kampagne spielen aber nachdem ich gesehen habe alle cutscenes sind
liegt die story ist scheiße und die wollen 60 euro für die kampagne und es ist irgendwelche
open world stells hatte ich da keinen bock drauf habe ich mir gedacht scheiße was spaßt in die
60 euro mal gucken nicht dass sogar mehr kostet 60 60 60 ja passt ja
nächstes splinter was ist es nur mit ihrem ganzen open world shit warum braucht jeder krampfhaft
eine open world gerade bei den letzten ubisoft spielen sieht man doch dass die ideen ausgehen
beziehungsweise die welt gar nicht mehr sinnvoll mit inhalten gefüllt werden kann ganz ehrlich was
war an assassins creed 2 zum beispiel jetzt so schlecht das war keine open world in dem sinn
du hattest verschiedene städte die dann aber mehr oder weniger open world waren das war open
world city quasi weiß ich ob es ein eigenes wort für gibt aber das war doch vollkommen in ordnung
das stimmt aber ich glaube so wirklich so wirklich so wirklich schlecht fand fand das eigentlich
kaum einer ich meine das hat call of duty eigentlich mit entwickelt dieses schlauch
level bombast inszenierung da kann man zwar call of duty für kritisieren aber es ist irgendwie
ein bisschen dran vorbei man das ist das was es mit ausmacht aber trotzdem es ist ja ein
unterschied zwischen nur schlauch level und nur open world es gibt ja auch noch durchaus
sinnvolle sachen dazwischen also assassins creed 2 ist so eines der paradebeispiele die man die mir
so einfallen das war nicht krampfhaft open world aber es hatte einen roten roten faden und trotzdem
drum herum ganz gut was zu entdecken ich finde dieses krampf hafte open world das muss doch
nicht sein warum eigentlich warum muss das unbedingt alles open world sein das nächste
splinter sein muss dann auch open world sein warum also ich verstehe es nicht ja und ganz
ehrlich ich muss ja auch eh sagen assassins creed 2 ist mit abstand mein lieblings assassins creed
ich glaube das geht den meisten so die das damals schon gespielt haben das hatte eine coole story
das hatte einen coolen protagonist da war noch nicht so ein blödsinn wie multiplayer dabei weiß ich
ob bei assassins creed wirklich jemand jemals nach multiplayer gefragt hat die unlocks waren
genau richtig es gab nicht 30 milliarden sachen aber es gab genug also ich fand assassins creed 2
war super etzio stels mr. wali dankeschön für den sub
da muss ich sagen das habe ich das habe ich nie weit gespielt das finden alle so geil aber ich
das ist eine gute frage weißt du warum dann durch den schnee im garten stels video so viele aufrufe
hat nein das kann ich dir auch nicht beantworten youtube war eines morgens da kann ich mich noch
dran erinnern der meinungs auf die startzeit packen zu müssen und da war mein video wenn ich weiß
wovon ich sprich ich spreche davon ein video wo ich sechs minuten lang nichts anderes mache außer
durch meinen garten im schnee laufen mein zugefrorenen teich zeige zwischenzeitlich sage oh man ist der
schnee tief oder sowas dabei ist das für die ist das für die schweizer halt der komplette witz
dann laufe ich weiter zeigte zugefrorene tannen dann laufe ich weiter ins gartenhäuschen dann
gucke ich da ins gartenhäuschen rein zeigt den kamin der ober gebaut hat dann gehe ich hinter
zeigt irgendwie so einen haufen wo irgendwie paar igel drunter wohnen da genau und dann zeige ich
die mülltonne und dann laufe ich wieder vor ja das ist auch die pumpe die zugefroren ist das
war es also in diesem video passiert nichts nichts die watch time die kann ich jetzt nicht sagen
sekunde ich muss mir kurz muten alter knees action knees anfall so und jetzt laufe ich
wieder zurück also kompletter schwachsinn es gibt überhaupt keinen sinn warum dieses video
empfohlen wurde von youtube aber youtube hat im algorithmus uns fertig eines morgens war
der kram auf der startseite und das wurde promote ich meine das hat auch schlechtes like also ich
meine für meine verhältnisse hat es ein schlechtes like dislike verhältnis warum weil die leute das
video empfohlen bekommen haben und sich gefragt haben was ist das passiert da noch irgendwas
jetzt hau mal raus was dein ingame name zu world of warcraft zeiten wer sagt denn dass es
world of warcraft war nein mein ingame name verrate ich nicht da findet man nämlich ein
paar sachen von mir damals das will ich nicht unter anderem wo ich richtig dumm
rumgeflammt habe aber das ist nicht das hauptproblem es gab nämlich damals auch
mmos wo ich gespielt habe eine community seite wo es heute noch archive von gibt mit servers
und in game namen und fotos dabei da habe ich auch da habe ich auch eingeschickt was von mir damals
hast du schon dieses youtube pass auf jetzt wird rick rolled nein ich habe ganz youtube
deutschland ausgewertet und analysiert ist schön schön für ihn und was hat er rausgefunden das
ergebnis ok das ergebnis
stand da eben ja und ich will mir das jetzt ich habe eigentlich zu big brain für heute
abend und weiter top video ok dann können wir uns gucken wir uns dann gucken wir uns dann
gleich an wenn das wenn das top ist dann wenn der chat sagt es geht nur sechs minuten er
analysiert die bubbles auf youtube nach verbindung der abos mehr da bin ich wahrscheinlich nicht
drauf aber dem scale garantiert nicht der youtube quats und ich youtube obis auf quats erinnert
mich so ein bisschen an warts das war doch auch das war doch dieses zombie dayz in schlecht warts
bei the way wo wir gerade dabei sind tradition hat das ganze schon sekunde steams stats new world
steams stats battlefield guck mal steams charts halo wie das aktuell aussieht die leute spielen
jetzt ja gerade kampagne aber nicht aktualisiert ok ich denke mal heute soll es aber eigentlich
neuesten höchsten stand haben ok leute bevor ich jetzt aufmache new world die haben wir jetzt
letzten sind patch released habe ich mitbekommen was meint ihr hat das spiel nach dem patch jetzt
wieder mehr spieler oder weniger ich weiß es legit nicht ich habe keine ahnung oder keine
auswirkung keine auswirkung weniger oder mehr ich würde eigentlich also bei jedem anderen mmo würde
ich sagen nach einem content drop kommen bestimmt wieder 20 30 prozent dazu aber bei new world
ehrlich ok schauen wir mal ja es ist ein bisschen doch es ist tatsächlich nicht wirklich doch
das letzte mal wo ich geguckt habe 100.000 peak meine güte ist das die haben server gemärcht habe
ich gelesen ja server merge der erste server merge und wisst ihr was ich witzig finde ich
habe zu new world wo diese ganzen ich habe keine ahnung ob man das findet new world froh über
warte schlange oder sowas twitter keine ahnung ich habe auf twitter sowas geschrieben wie die
leute werden noch froh sein und sich zurück erinnern an die zeit wo new world ward warte
schlange hatte und guck mal der erste server merge ist schon am start das ging aber schnell
ich glaube ich habe bei keinem mmo bisher erlebt dass quasi zwei monate oder wie lange ist das
raus das ist doch nicht viel länger draußen es kam raus oktober was ist denn das ja ok oktober
november ja ja zwei zwei monate zwei monate ziemlich genau zwei monate ich habe es noch
nie erlebt dass nach zwei monaten eines mmo releases server gemärcht werden ja ja die haben
server gemärcht guck mal hier das ist wirklich also sekunde ich muss mal mein headset ein
ausstöpsel das macht komische dinger so jetzt wunderbar ok also das ist das ist wirklich
richtig richtig verkackt server zusammenlegung als reaktion auf spieler schwund wisst ihr was
ich merkwürdig finde wie machen die das eigentlich in new world in new world ist ja ein relativ
player driven mmo mit mit gebieten die du claimen kannst und crafting zeugs was du verkaufen kannst
und sowas wenn die jetzt zwei server merken ist es ja eine sache einem reinen wir wie kreisel
kreinden bis uns dahinter wund ist für neue gear scores kein problem aber wie ist das bei
new world manchmal ich merke zwei server und jeweils unterschiedliche gilden haben gebiete
und städte geklämt wer gewinnt dann also welche gilde hat er nach dem server merkt
es wird das random meist oder was welche gilde hat er nach dem server merkt die stadt die von
server eins oder die von sowas das ist klassischer fall von merck konflikt geht merck server und
geht nicht muss man wim diff aufmachen deine mutter hat das gebiet ok wie lang spiel die
schon immer muss alle verlieren alles das ist eigentlich die einzig sinnvolle sache die du
machen kannst ja die einzig sinnvolle was du machen kannst ist komplett den neuen surfer
anklämt lassen und die gilden sich kloppen lower server verlieren das wäre typische amazon
handling der ganzen geschichte naja gut wundert mich wundert mich nix mehr ach ja
battlefield 23.000 ok man muss der fairness halber sagen natürlich kommt da noch origin
dabei und bei den gesamt gesamt spielzahlen kommen natürlich auch konsolen dabei aber
rennen bleiben wir nur beim pc origin fehlt und ich denke mal viele werden über origin spielen
aber trotzdem mein der trend der trend wird auch nicht anders aussehen auf origin wichtig
monka giga ich meine die haben einfach mal zwei drittel verloren mehr mehr mehr 70 prozent
haben sie verloren ungefähr das ist krass das ist echt heftig das geht ja noch schneller als
bei new world und selbst wenn du das jetzt mal hochrechnest irgendwie auf origin oder
so dann haben die in origin vielleicht lass mal lass mal das doppel design ja lass mal
das doppel design also lass noch mal lass noch mal 50.000 draufkommen in origin dann
ist das ganz schön wenig wusste die eigentlich dass die sales relativ gut waren die sales waren
ziemlich gut die waren knapp hinter battlefield 3 die sache ist plus die warum waren die sales
gut naja weil die uns mit trailer und alle möglichen gebated haben long term ist ja die
frage die erste woche hat hat da jetzt natürlich schon was zu auszusagen weil es gibt spiele die
verkaufen nicht mal ansatzweise so viel das ist also es gibt wenig spiele die so viel verkaufen
aber trotzdem die refunds haben die bestimmt nicht mit reingerechnet gehe ich nicht von aus
das muss ja gut aussehen ja aber ganz ehrlich warten wir mal ab das wird ein krasser drop an
spieler werden ich würde nicht sagen das wird ich bin es ist schon ein krasser drop an spieler
guck mal wenn wir davon ausgehen es haben wirklich sagen wir mal vier millionen leute das gekauft
und es sind 70 prozent einfach davon weg und das ist ja ich meine es wird ja immer weniger da
machst du nix außer vielleicht ein gutes game wenn du ein gutes game machst dann hast du nicht
das problem ich überlege mir gerade es gab ja mal zeiten so zum beispiel auch der so was
wollen wir vor kraft release und sowas das sind spiele quasi noch mit der zeit quasi und den
spielern und dem content quasi gewachsen das ist natürlich gut gelauncht und das hatte auch den
berechtigten halb damals aber das ging einfach nach und nach noch weiter nach oben und ich finde
das muss auch so sein aber aktuell ist es ja eher so spiele kommen raus und sterben fast schon
ins sind wenn ich mir überlege wie viel shit rausgekommen ist die letzten jahre wie viel hat
denn fallout 76 leute steam charts fallout nicht dass ich jetzt bevor ich miss guck gibt
es das überhaupt auf steam fallout 76 die nicht dass das irgendwie jubis oft juli ju wie heißt
denn das jubilä jubilä wie heißt der ubisoft launcher noch einmal das war jubilä oder ach
moment das ist gar nicht ubisoft ich hab's für so leute ich hab's ich hab's verwechselt jaja
das ist prozess alles gar nicht ubisoft stimmt stimmt das ist das ist der typ mit six times
die detail oder sowas das habe ich jetzt habe ich gerade durch den weiß ich wie ich auch alles
gleiche kacke so also das gibt es anscheinend auf steam und jetzt gucken wir mal wie viele leute
das spielen wollen wir mal raten steam charts ach nee hier ist schon ok es hat gespoilert
steam charts naja so viele
ich mein das ist die hälfte von battlefield 2042
das ist gar nicht so scheiße hey guck mal das kam vor zwei jahren raus naja eineinhalb jahren
kam vor eineinhalb jahren raus und das hat ungefähr so viele spieler quasi jetzt anteilmäßig immer
noch also verloren insgesamt wie battlefield schauen wir nach titanfall 2 steam charts ja aber
titanfall 2 ist leider ziemlich dead ja leider ich glaube es hat ihm ein bisschen geholfen dass es
free to play war eine ganze zeit lang oder ist es immer noch free to play weiß das jemand oder
war das nun nur ein wochenende oder eine woche oder ein monat oder es war eine zeit lang free
to play das weiß ich stimmt origin kommt dann auch drauf ja das ist richtig ja oh leute jetzt
jetzt machen wir mal ein wisst ihr wisst ihr was mir gerade so einfällt sekunde wenn ich
wenn ich tippe werdet ihr werden steam charts wolzen alter kann sich noch einer dran erinnern
wolzen die haben es voll verschissen 411 wolzen ist er wirklich abgeschissen ich weiß übrigens
bis heute nicht weil wolzen überhaupt richtig ausspricht team fortress 2 ist ganz gut team
fortress 2 muss ich nicht gucken team fortress 2 ist ziemlich gut ich glaube sie sind hauptsächlich
bots in team fortress 2 aber team fortress 2 ist ziemlich gut alter wolzen skyrim steam charts
die abloh kann ich nicht gucken die abloh hat ist ja nicht auf steam wir müssen wir müssen nach
ultimate oder oder so gucken special special edition mal hier das ist gar nicht schlecht
das ist ja es schauen mir mehr leute zu als fast mehr leute zu als sie wolzen spielen
aber guck mal und das ist mal richtig heftig gelauncht hat dann gespiked war broken as fuck
und dann ist wieder runter ach noch was anderes das das war tatsächlich eines der bettel royals
die ich die mir in der beta phase recht recht spaß gemacht haben mal gucken wie das abgeht
genauso scheiße alle die haben sie die haben es auch so verkackt alter hiress ist auch so
ein so ein krampf komischer laden meine güte was ist was was was ist eigentlich mit den games los
die aktuell rauskommen haben da mal irgendwas gescheites wobei das stimmt nicht dass das tut
den leuten unrecht die wirklich gute games programmieren gibt es gibt es gibt wirklich
gerade wenn man mal bei steam die ein oder anderen projekte von kleinen entwicklern anguckt
ist wirklich gut zum beispiel richtig nice das game wer auf so sim park oder so was steht stand
ist wirklich cool also wer spaß an so aufbau dingen hat dass es macht wirklich bock
bettel net games nähe kann ich echt nur empfehlen
streamst du das macht ne das ist mega langweilig zu streamen zum zugucken gehe ich mal von aus
das wird ein gutes jahr für zocker dann schauen wir mal was davon gut geworden ist
soll verbackt wie sau sein habe ich gehört spiele nicht aber wohl insgesamt schon ganz ok so ist
wohl an sich richtig gutes game also ich gucke ja follow krabi ab und zu und das scheint wirklich
nice zu sein das muss man wieder in echtzeit strategie spielen sein seit jahren was sich
lohnt pokemon snap keine ahnung wusste ich weiß ich nicht mal dass es überhaupt gegeben
hat er sagt mir gar nichts wie interessiert es interessiert wobei also ich weiß ich ob
das tatsächlich top games 2021 sind aber das soll tatsächlich gar nicht schlecht gewesen sein
auto keine ahnung dass das war das ist wohl richtig gut wenn man koop spiel spielen will
das kam doch das kam doch nicht mal was schreibe was was dafür blödsinn drin
new world battlefield ok das hat verkackt hallo infinite muss jetzt mal zeigen was sie was sie
machen das sehr eine bescheuerte liste aber es war schon viel mist also es ist schon viel viel in
die hose gegangen nicht nur dieses jahr auch die letzten jahre über wie gesagt ford auf 7 die
sechs wolzen hatten wir noch am start battlefield new world warcraft 3 die forcht und wahrscheinlich
fällt mir noch jede menge anderes ein wenn ich mal kurz in mich gehe es ist gerade so wettbewerb
wer kann es noch mehr verkacken ernsthaft wirklich die sind die sind auch maximal hängen geblieben
alle oder übrigens wisst ihr was twitter twitter hat heute wieder das das gemacht was twitter am
besten kann ich habe geschrieben cyberpunk natürlich natürlich was wie konnte ich jetzt
instan nicht ans cyberpunk denken so ich habe ich hatte heute auf twitter geschrieben hat jemand
eine übrigens chat gebe ich jetzt mal an euch weiter die frage hat jemand eine gute empfehle
für eine kleine usw 600 va reichen locker also voltampere reichen locker die usw muss auch
weiter laufen wenn der akku alt oder defekt ist das ganze natürlich solange kein stromausfall
ist auf herstellerangaben kann man sich nicht verlassen also kein hören sagen empfehlungen
please keine hören sagen empfehlungen please und jetzt dürft ihr mal raten was meint ihr wie
viele dieser zehn antworten sind hören sagen ja mehr oder weniger alle eigentlich oh ja was
habe ich ja ausgeblendet so kommt da anders anstatt habe ich ihn gefragt hast du das auch mal
ausprobiert meinte er nein sehr gut apc kannst du auf bypass stellen ich will ihn ja auf bypass
stellen ich will dass alles weiter läuft sollte mir die batterie verrecken so das ist hören sagen
das ist hören sagen weil apc hat ja auch hunderttausende usw auch hören sagen auch hören sagen
auch hören sagen also ich schreibe extra schon dabei also chat wenn irgendeiner von euch eine
gute empfehlung hat ich möchte eine usw haben die nicht mein komplettes rack ausschaltet nur wenn
die batterie verreckt also eigentlich das was man früher als offline oder passiv oder oder
allein interactive usw bezeichnet hat ich möchte keine online usw haben es hat keiner geschrieben
dass er was im einsatz hat es haben welche geschrieben sie haben apc im einsatz ok ja
das stimmt ja nicht das ist ja nicht das was ich haben will ich will kein überspannung schutz
ich will eine usw die usw macht aber solange der strom am stromnetz funktioniert und die
batterie verreckt dann hinter die sachen nicht ausgehen ja also weiß ich vielleicht auch zu
unpro unpräzise formuliert von mir im auf twitter übrigens wisst ihr was ich heute gelesen habe die
brasilianische sprecherin hier mercy brasil die wurde ermordet die ja das habe ich heute
irgendwie die brasilianische sprecherin von von mercy wurde ermordet von einem typ habe ich habe
ich in newsbeiträgen gelesen vielleicht gibt es da schon was neues vielleicht ist es outdated von
einem typ der gesagt haben sie festgenommen und er hat gesagt er hat aus notwehr selbstverteidigung
gehandelt und seine begründung war dass die voice actress vom teufel besessen gewesen sein soll
oder denke ich mir auch nur was ist denn das für eine begründung also ich weiß nicht was mit den
leuten los ist ja also wenn ich mir manche leute angucke da habe ich auch das gefühl die sind vom
teufel besessen so im übertragenen sinne ich glaube ja nicht an den ganzen kram aber deswegen
darf man sie trotzdem nicht erschießen auch wenn man vielleicht gerne will also das ist auch wieder
echt ach so ja wir wollen uns das video angucken stimmt ok wir kommen uns das video jetzt an leute
machen wir jetzt aber kurz die musik aus ich war die letzten monat ein bisschen beschäftigt
es gibt diesen kommentar aus den new york times der vor etwa drei jahren eine ziemlich große
welle gemacht hat youtube the great radikalizer hier drin wird in nur wenigen absetzen behauptet
dass youtube's fokus auf wiedergabezeit und den typischen ein video geht noch effekt gleichzeitig
aber auch dafür sorgt dass eine simple suche nach der letzten presskonferenz innerhalb weniger
empfehlung zur hasse erfülltem und oder des informieren im material führen kann dieser
ich könnte mir tatsächlich vorstellen dass da was dran ist allerdings ist youtube ja mittlerweile
dabei dass etwas zu zu filtern ja also du hast bei corona leugner videos ja schon dran stehen
mittlerweile youtube fact check da wird bestimmt auch einiges weg gefiltert aber das ist prinzipiell
das problem gibt könnte ich mir schon vorstellen artikel war zum großteil dafür verantwortlich
dass youtube seinen empfehlungsalgorithmus angepasst hat und jetzt hin und wieder zu
den wikipedia artikeln beliebter themen von verschwörungskanälen verlinkt doch das war
alles vor der pandemie wie sieht das alles jetzt aus wie sind youtube und damit auch
die pfade die es für sein publikum vorschlägt strukturiert bin ich da irgendwo drauf eine
studie aus dem letzten jahr zeigt beispielsweise einen politischen zusammenhang zwischen dem
glauben an eine verschwörung und der nutzung sozialer medien ja das wundert mich nicht
und einen negativen zusammenhang zwischen dem einhalten von hygieneschutzmaßnahmen und dem
konsum von social media ja insbesondere dass das wundert mich gar nicht ich habe letztens
erst noch gesagt und das war nun ein bauchgefühl von mir aber das wird hier bestätigt ich habe
den eindruck die ganzen social justice warrior sind auf twitter und die corona leugner sind
auf youtube so als hätten sich beide chefs mal getroffen haben gesagt hier den wilsten
haben und dann hat twitter gesagt wir nehmen die und youtube hat gesagt ach komm dann nehmen
wir die andere und facebook hat gesagt wir nehmen sie alle in noch schlimmere ausprägung in einer
weiteren befragung mit 30 leuten die an die 29 von ihnen an dass sie durch inhalte auf
youtube an was für eine verschwörung ach flat earth das das sind mir auch die liebsten die
eine ausnahme gab anstatt dessen von der eigenen tochter überzeugt worden zu sein die das alles
wiederum auch von youtube hatte so sondernlich viel kann ja nicht passiert sein es ist genauso
wie wir letztes video geguckt haben könnt ihr euch vielleicht noch daran erinnern dass der
grand canyon auch in einer woche oder in zwei wochen entstanden ist weil durch noahs flut so
viel wasser da war dass das schneller ging das war ja die begründung letztendlich das war auch
gestört gerne sehen können ich würde gerne sehen wie er mit wem in verbindung steht ob es
wirklich eine konspirative parallelwelt auf youtube gibt und wo ich und andere kanäle die ich kenne
und gucke auf dieser karte zu verorten sind naja das habe ich dann auch gemacht und damit habe ich
bereits vor über einem jahr angefangen huge big data data science hier am start was auch immer ich
herauszufinden versuche es reicht nicht mir 10 bis 20 kanäle anzugucken und das dann auf die
gesamte plattform anzuwenden youtube ist dynamisch riesengroß aber zum glück auch mit einer offenen
programmier schnitt stelle versehen ich suche mir also ja ja moment moment aus der jetzt die
dislikes auch entfernt werden am 13 december händisch heraus die auf jeden fall in dieser
analyse auftauchen sollen das ist zu diesem zeitpunkt das who is who deutscher korona leugner
dann suche ich mir innerhalb von zwei intervallen die kanäle heraus die diese kanäle abonniert
haben oder auf die sie auf ihrer profilseite verweisen dabei kommen etliche hinzu im zweiten
intervall mache ich das für die im ersten intervall gefundenen kanäle noch mal und es
kommt noch sehr viel mehr dazu das mit korona leugnern zu machen ist besonders witzig weil
die gefundenen kanalanzahl dabei exponentiell ansteigt so habe ich innerhalb kürzester zeit
etwa 15.000 kanäle von denen über die hälfte weniger als 1000 videoaufrufe hat also fallen
die raus zusammen mit den kanälen sind nicht nur die verbindung zu anderen kanälen protokolliert
sondern auch deren damaliger abonnenten stand das zugewiesene land die insgesamten videoaufrufe
das erstellt datum und das lieblings pokemon diese daten beginne ich also auszuwerten die
zum jetzigen zeitpunkt nur eine unglaublich hässliche tabelle mit viel zu vielen spalten
ist die leider noch überhaupt nicht dabei hilft aber das hat er bestimmt nicht in excel oder
ansonsten würde ich würde ich die generelle vorgehensweise etwas in frage stellen sich
youtube struktur genauer vorzustellen was habe ich gerade noch gesagt youtube ist dynamisch
genau youtube ist dynamisch was also auch immer bei meiner datenerhebung im letzten jahr rauskommt
es gilt heute vielleicht gar nicht mehr was auch immer das für soziale implikation hat man könnte
theoretisch sagen dass das ja nur eine momentaufnahme ist die sich in rasender geschwindigkeit wieder
ändern kann ja also habe ich das alles noch mal gemacht im august 2021 habe ich mit denselben
händisch herausgesuchten ursprungskanälen wieder bei youtube im papier müll gewühlt und daraus
noch mal etwa 7500 kanäle erhoben dann kam der spannende teil die visualisierung und dabei kann
ich natürlich nicht einfach die kanäle als knoten in einem netzwerk verschieben wie es mir lieb ist
denn wo und in welche entfernung diese zu anderen stehen ist natürlich auch wichtig also habe ich
ein algorithmus wer ist das wer ist das hier mit der katz weiß das jemand also habe ich ein
algorithmus rüber laufen lassen der nicht miteinander verbundene kanäle abstößt und
kanäle die miteinander verbunden sind einander annähern lässt das ist ein netzwerk in dem
visuelle nähe auch eine stärkere vernetzung untereinander bedeutet und bereits hier kann
man sehen dass sich da gewisse lager bilden diese lager sind durch eine modularitätsanalyse das sieht
aus als hat einer paar farbdinger an die wand gespritzt was aber für sowas gar gar nicht mal
schlecht ist ich hätte okay ich hätte nicht gesagt ich erwarte ich hätte erwartet dass das
so aussieht aber ich hätte mir so was in der richtung schon vorgestellt dass es nämlich
komplett random verteilt ist kann ja schwachsinn gewesen dass du quasi gleichmäßig überall
gleich viel hast das kann ja nicht sein auch mathematisch nachweisbar so gibt es zum beispiel
hier unten das lager populärer englischsprachiger youtuber wie casey nice dad pewdiepie oder jenna
marbles hier oben befindet sich das deutschsprachige äquivalent wir sitzen unter anderem le floyd my
lab kultmirror und le floyd guckt das überhaupt noch jemand ich habe von den floyd glaube ich
irgendwie letzten drei jahre nichts mehr mitbekommen weiter oben geht es dann eher in eine deutsch und
englischsprachige ecke von lifestyle beauty und kochkanälen und diese fast kugelförmige blase
hier unten die ein bisschen abseits vom rest steht ja das ist das verschwörungsklaster wohlgemerkt
nur dass oder reitschuss das auch am start jeder einzelne meiner händische herausgesuchten
corona leutner befindet sich alter klagemauer tv ist auch so ein ding von denen habe ich mal ein
video empfohlen gekriegt da ging es um korona und negative energie und sowas alter das war ganz ganz
wir also das ich habe noch nicht mal verstanden was die einem überhaupt sagen wollen hier und
zahlreiche weitere auch noch mal langsam diese konspirativen kanäle sind nicht wie sie gerne
behaupten einzelne leute aus der mitte der gesellschaft sie sind nicht streuselkuchen
artig über das gesamte netzwerk verteilt und normale mitglieder dieser sozialen umgebung
nein die sitzen alle hier auf engstem raum am kindertisch sie sind im wahrsten sinne des
wortes ran figure die in dem monothematischsten und am stärksten untereinander und am schwächsten mit
anderen kanälen verbundenen cluster rumhängen dieses cluster ist das parade beispiel einer
echokammer eines sozialen raums in dem die eigene meinung nur ich denke mal ich denke mal wenn man
da verschiedene sachen schwerpunkte am anfang reingenommen würdest du das bei vielen themen
finden und ich könnte mir vorstellen je nachdem welche themen du auswählst hat man eine ganz
gute trefferquote dass immer die gleichen immer die gleichen channels rauskommen es gibt einfach
so sachen die das kommt das eine zum anderen nicht herausgefordert wird das kann man schon
vermutet haben und eigentlich wirklich überraschen aber bisher gab es halt hauptsächlich nur
behauptungen und wie dynamisch ist das ganze nun naja die unterschied jetzt was hat er jetzt
eigentlich geguckt der hat die channel sich ausgesucht dann hat er geschaut welche videos
da drauf sind über die api und hat dann bei der api abgefragt was empfohlene videos von diesen
videos aus sind oder wie ja das jetzt eigentlich genau gemacht habt ihr das kapiert oder hat er
das nicht so hat er sich erklärt also mich würde es mal interessieren wie das wie das funktioniert
gegenseitig gesappt ach so naja gut wer wen gegenseitig gesappt hat dass die ähnliche
interessen haben das wundert mich jetzt ja gar nicht ja da muss es dir da musste die im
endeffekt irgendeine wie soll ich sagen irgendein ein thema raussuchen fünf channels davon und
dann wirst du immer die gleichen finden also nicht das schwachsinn aber immer ähnliche finden wenn
es noch mal laufen lässt das wird ja jetzt schwachsinn was ich erzähle 2020 und august 2021 sind
überschaubar entsprechend erwartbar ist es also dass es aktuell und in naher zukunft noch sehr
sehr ähnlich aussieht was ich aber durch diese zwei zeit unbeabsichtigt erfasst habe ist die
sperrung von einigen kanälen wie ken fm und deren auswirkungen auf das netzwerk stimmte gab es ja
auch mal hat zwar sein damals prominentesten repräsentanten verloren aber die stabilisieren
gibt es denn eigentlich noch oder ist er jetzt auf wegen einer alternativen plattform unterwegs
hat es die sene kaum in einigen fällen schafften es aber auch nicht konspirative kanäle in das
dazugehörige cluster und zwar weil sie hauptsächlich von konspirativen mitgliedern
des netzwerks abonniert waren und damit durch den algorithmus in die nähe dieses clusters gerutscht
sind es geht aber auch gar nicht um einzelne kanäle sondern um die gesamtaussage dieses
netzwerks und seiner struktur der implikation die es für youtube und dessen empfehlungen hat und
die sind ziemlich eindeutig leute die dieses video schauten sahen auch führt mit dieser plattform
struktur nur tiefer in den strudel der widersinnigkeit oktober steht kurz vor der zellzeitung da hat es
gute sachen ausgedacht ist tatsächlich noch immer der große radikalisierer und das ist furchtbar schade
na gut es ist ja bei anderen sachen auch so das heißt nicht umsonst influencer was meint ihr warum
die anderen so auf einem haufen hängen das ist jetzt halt ein themenschwerpunkt bei dem anderen
ist das ist der themenschwerpunkt lifestyle oder beauty und lifestyle oder sonst was je nachdem was
du dir raussuchst ist das halt so und das heißt nicht umsonst influencer aber ja das hätte also
die eigentliche sache die eigentliche grundaussage hätte mich auch gewundert wenn da was anderes
rauskommt im prinzip geht es ja gar nicht so sehr darum kurz mal gucken wo die wo habe ich
jetzt meine musik irgendwie sich zu informieren oder weiterzubilden oder wie auch immer eigentlich
geht es überall in auf youtube twitter social media geschichten darum sich selbst immer wieder
zu bestätigen und zu beweisen dass man selbst auch richtig liegt und sich quasi selbst so
gegenseitig so ein bisschen so über den kopf zu streiten und sagen ja du hast recht und dann
zu seinen mit bubble angehörigen zu sagen ja ja die anderen sind böse aber zum glück sind wir
die erleuchteten haben den durchblick und wissen wie es läuft das ist eigentlich der sinn es geht
da keine mehr drum irgendwie was zu verbessern oder so sondern eigentlich nur um sich selbst zu
bestätigen das ist ja aussehen und zweck der ganzen sache zu suchen mal in das bild mehr
wahrscheinlich finde ich mich da nicht ist zu wenig der link zum netzwerk im hires ihr netzwerk
ja wir das genau gemacht dann wird mich weiter gar das ding eine suche png bringt jetzt nicht viel
die tabelle bei gut gut gewesen weil solange man das soll man das nicht durch nicht nicht suchen
kann poste
Wieviel RAM Auslastung hat mein Browser?
Will nicht, oh je.
Vielleicht kackt der Browser ab, ne, das liet nicht.
Wie läuft's an der Börse?
Gar nicht.
Ne, das liet nicht.
Ok, Download.
Mediafire.
70 MB PNG, Alter.
Oh ja, Opera GX.
Ich mach mal kurz meine Winners vm an.
Wir gucken uns Opera GX noch, ne.
Will ich die wirklich im Stream zeigen?
Weil, auf der anderen Seite, wenn ich jetzt schon das Sponsoring abgelehnt hab, warum soll
ich die dann zeigen?
Dann kriegen sie ja umsonst Werbung.
So.
Wir machen es jetzt auf, pass mal auf, wir machen jetzt Strik 17.
Wir machen es jetzt in VLC auf.
Ne, das ist eigentlich bescheuert, das in VLC aufzumachen.
Scheiße.
Aha.
Ok, wen haben wir hier unten?
Was ist hier so?
Tja, wer mich findet, gewinnt ein Sub.
Ich bin da wahrscheinlich nicht drauf.
Rammstein Official, alles klar.
Challenge Accepted.
Hat Tutorial, die gibt es auch noch.
Ok, kein Plan, also.
InScore, ok.
Hier sind wir in der Lifestyle Ecke.
Ungespielt, ok.
Ich glaube, wir sind schon mal ungefähr in der richtigen Ecke, aber ich muss ein deutlich
kleinerer, kleinerer Kasten sein, wenn überhaupt.
Wenn überhaupt.
Sowas da in der Richtung von der Größe vielleicht.
Ich glaube, ganzen Gaming, Gaming Sache ist da gar nicht so wirklich, wirklich drauf.
Ich meine, Unga hat ja auch mit Gaming wenig am Hut, das ist irgendwelche Reactions.
InScore ist Lifestyle, Stels.
Tja, man müsste die Daten irgendwie durchsuchen können, also ich suche mich jetzt hier nicht.
So, wenn Peet's Meet sogar nur so klein ist, dann bin ich da gar nicht drauf.
Ctrl F im PNG, alles klar.
Ah, dann nicht, cool, aber zu.
Ja, tatsächlich relativ interessant, das Video, was cool wäre, hätte er seinen Crawling-Skript
Github gepusht oder so, mir hätte interessiert, was er genau gemacht hat.
Gibt es kein online PNG OCR, ich glaube, das funktioniert da drauf nicht gescheit, da ist
ein Overlay drauf und Striche dazwischen und Farben und sonst wie Punkte und so, ich glaube,
das verwirrt, das verwirrt das Ganze nur.
Außerdem 70 MB PNG OCR, was dauert wahrscheinlich auch ewig, ist ja riesengroß.
Er hat doch nur die API benutzt oder nicht, nein, die API alleine bringt dir ja nichts,
du musst die API-Daten abfragen und irgendwie verarbeiten und das kannst du ja nicht alles
von Hand machen.
Fände ich zumindest sehr merkwürdig, wenn er das alles da wirklich von Hand gemacht
hätte.
Habt ihr übrigens mitbekommen, morgen gibt es einen neuen Battlefield Patch, morgen
spielen wir eine Runde Battlefield wieder und gucken, ob jetzt mit Patch 3.1 alles besser
ist.
Es werden unter anderem Objectives auf dem Dach gefixt und sowas, das gucken wir uns
dann aber morgen an.
Jetzt schauen wir uns morgen an.
Halbe Stunde, was hast du für eine Leitung?
70 MB sollten eigentlich links wo eine halbe Stunde dauern.
Okay, Quaid.
Kommt dieses Jahr noch irgendwelche guten Games raus?
Halo kam heute raus.
Kommt noch irgendwas?
Hab ich irgendwas interessantes vergessen?
Na natürlich, keine Ahnung.
Sind ja im nächsten Jahr wieder Game Awards, wo man eigentlich nichts drauf geben muss,
was da gewinnt ist jetzt nicht zwangsläufig das beste Game, sondern wahrscheinlich das,
was am besten die Jury bestochen hat oder so, keine Ahnung, also Game Awards da ist,
das geht mir auch am Arsch vorbei.
Spielst du den Singleplayer im Streamline?
Ich kaufe mir den Singleplayer wahrscheinlich gar nicht, ich hab mich nämlich spoilern
lassen.
Ich hab mir die Story, es gibt ein Video, das hat zweieinhalb Stunden die Halo Cutscenes
drinne.
Ich hab mir die Story schon angeguckt und die Story ist scheiße, finde ich.
Auf Open World stellts, im Halo Universum hab ich eh keinen Bock.
Also, ich werd die Story nicht spielen.
Ich hab übrigens Multiplayer ranked gespielt, Halo.
Ich bin Platin 3, fast Platin 4, ja, Plattchat lebt.
Das ist nicht gut, glaube.
Gibt's so was wie Halo Infinite Rank Distribution?
Ah, hier, ok, also es sind zwölf, äh, nee, zwölf, achtzehn, äh, eins, zwei.
Also, es sind zwanzig Tiers unter mir und, ähm, drei, neun, zehn über mir.
Also, zehn Tiers über mir, zwanzig Tiers unter mir.
Das scheint ja, sagen wir mal so, noch in der fetten mittleren Kurve zu sein, aber doch
schon ein bisschen eher auf der rechten Seite.
Also, quasi, also quasi, äh, hier so müsste das dann sein.
Also, nicht wirklich krass gut oder so.
Also, ich hoffe vielleicht schaff ich's noch irgendwie in Diamond, wobei ich das Gefühl
habe, natürlich, natürlich denkt man immer, die anderen cheaten und so, ihr wisst, wie
das ist.
Besseres Mittelfeld, genau, könnte man sagen.
Ich hab ja auch, guck mal, ich hab insgesamt, äh, 28 Stunden Halo oder so und nie großartig
Erfahrung, also ich find dafür geht's schon halbwegs.
Ähm, was wollte ich jetzt sagen?
Ich hab das Gefühl, manche cheaten in Halo auf dem PC, also, manches kann ich mir anders,
äh, nicht richtig erklären.
Zumal ich Solo-Keyboard-Maus spiele, also da auch keine Controller mit Auto-Aim gematcht
werden oder so.
Aber auf der anderen Seite kann das natürlich auch sein, wobei ich mich halt frage, wenn
die in Platin teilweise die oberkrassen God-Amer sind und ich sidestappen kann, wie ich will
und die alle ihre Schüsse immer hitten, dann frage ich mich, wie das dann erst auf Platin
ist oder gar auf Onyx.
Ach ja, ich wollte mir eigentlich die Battlefield-Patchnotes eigentlich erst morgen angucken, aber schon
so ein kleiner Spoiler, was da morgen auf uns zukommt, weil es jemand im Chat gepostet
hat.
Die SMGs werden gebufft, also die Waffen mit denen ich eindeutig am meisten abgehe in dem
Spiel werden noch besser gemacht.
Ich mein, wir hatten da teilweise Games mit der MP9 oder der K30, wir haben die schon
echt, also, weggeklatscht, ist schon fast noch untertrieben.
Wir sind da einfach drüber gerutscht komplett.
Und wenn ihr das jetzt in Hipfire noch besser macht, ich mein, ich mach hier nur Hipfire
Kills.
Das Game lobt mich am Ende immer für 14 Hipfire Kills von 30 oder so.
30 Kills gemacht, jawoll, 14 Hipfire Kills.
Wenn das jetzt noch verbessert wird, wie wird das dann erst, wenn man da noch ein Laser
dran macht?
Also, übrigens, warum die LMGs noch besser gemacht werden, verstehe ich auch nicht.
Die LMGs sind aktuell schon mit die opesten Waffen, weil du halt 200 Schuss hast, keine
Ahnung.
Das Game ist eh hoffnungslos verloren.
Aber wir gucken uns das trotzdem morgen noch mal an und sei es nur ein bisschen zur Erheiterung.
Das weiß man halt nicht.
Es gibt auch Hacker, die sind so schlecht mit allem in dem Game, dass sie eben nicht
aufsteigen.
Weil gerade bei Halo kommt es halt noch auf viel mehr an, außer einfach nur krasses Aim.
Also, ich glaube, es gibt kaum ein Game, wo es so wichtig ist, vorausschauend sich zu
platzieren als in Halo, also fällt mir wenig ein.
Bei den meisten anderen Games mit etwas niedrigerer Time-to-Kill kannst du das alles durch Aiming
oder gutes Movement ausgleichen, aber Halo ist halt mega davon abhängig, wie du stehst,
wie du dich bewegst und am besten schon 3-4 Sekunden vorher.
Ja, bei Quake kannst du ja noch mehr durch Movement und Aiming ausgleichen.
Und vor allem durch Map-Timing mit Spawns von Power-Ups und so.
Aber das ist wirklich heftig und ich stehe auch oft falsch.
Also bei Halo Magik meistens weißt du, warum du verreckst.
Leider hat das Game auch so seine Probleme, wie beispielsweise Nahkampfankriffe, die nicht
registrieren oder mal jumpst du zum Gegner und hittest ihn mal nicht und das ist ein
bisschen inkonsistent, da müssen sie noch was dran machen, aber ansonsten macht das
wirklich Bock.
So, Gartenstelz kommt weg, Ubisoft Quartz kommt auch weg, Dislike, das gucken wir uns
jetzt nicht an.
Das können wir uns am Sonntag mal ansehen, weil ich fand das war wirklich ein richtig
gutes Video.
Keine Ahnung, hast du ein gutes Spiel für die Weihnachtsfeinde?
Ja, wenn du auf sowas stehst, Steam, das ist wirklich für mich so die Überraschung
der letzten paar Wochen gewesen, habe ich überhaupt nicht auf dem Radar gehabt und
wenn man auf so Aufbau-Steampark-Geschichten-Style-Spiele steht, ist das wirklich mega nice.
Ja, oder Rollercoaster Tycoon oder sowas, wobei nicht wirklich, doch, doch schon, aber
halt andere Setting, das macht mega Bock.
Kannst du mal auf dein Video reagieren, ich habe es vorhin kurz durchgeskippt und ich
habe wieder betont, dass ich nicht verstehen kann, warum YouTube das so promoted hat.
Keine Ahnung, das ist schwer zu sagen, wir kennen deinen Vater ja nicht.
Leute, ich habe immer noch ziemlich trockenen Hals, das merkt ihr wahrscheinlich auch, aber
es ist schon ein bisschen besser geworden als die letzten Tage davor, deswegen habe
ich jetzt auch ein bisschen weniger gestreamt, weil ich wollte erst, dass es besser wird.
Letzten Streams war ja noch schlimmer als heute, da habe ich ja laufend gehusstet und
irgendwas.
Ich trinke schon viel, ich muss alle 5 Minuten aufs Klo, postchamp.
Ja, Tee trinke ich auch morgens und mittags.
Jetzt trinke ich einfach nur Wasser.
Ich finde die meisten Weihnachtsgeschenke sind wahnsinnig sinnlos, die braucht halt
keiner und nachdem die Leute auch alle alt genug und sagen wir mal Geld genug haben,
muss ich das zu kaufen, das ist meistens auch Schwachsinn.
Ich mache relativ viel daheim, aber trotzdem ist es natürlich erholsamer, wie Arbeitsstelle
zu machen den ganzen Tag.
Übrigens, bevor ich in Urlaub gegangen bin, hatten wir auf der Arbeit noch so eine Veranstaltung,
wo es ein bisschen Ansprache gab für das nächste Jahr und irgendwie hat sich jemand
von denen, der da war, dazu hinreißen lassen, was zu erzählen, dass man maximal 2 Tage die
Woche Homeoffice machen kann.
Ich meine, das ist nicht in Stein gegossen, das ist irgendein Typ auf wegen der Veranstaltung,
der das gesagt hat, aber da ist schon was dran, weil das war jemand, der darf sowas
sagen, aber wisst ihr was ich machen werde, sollte das wirklich der Fall sein, was ja
komplett am aktuellen Geschehen vorbeigeht und auch komplett an dem, was man die letzten
Jahre gesehen hat, wie es funktioniert und auch komplett an der aktuellen Jobsituation
im IT-Markt vorbeigeht, die ersten haben schon gekündigt, 2 Leute, weiß ich schon, sind
nächstes Jahr nicht mehr da bei uns, die haben instant gesagt, piss dich also und sind
weg.
Aber wisst ihr was ich machen werde, wenn das wirklich kommt, aktuell ist es ja so,
ich arbeite 4 Tage die Woche und davon 3 Tage Homeoffice, das finde ich auch von der Verteilung
her gut, dann stellt man einmal die Woche fest, wie ineffektiv es eigentlich ist, in ein
Büro zu hocken und 3 Tage die Woche kann man was machen.
So, wenn das wirklich so kommt, dass sie sagen, maximal 2 Tage Homeoffice, was gerade für IT-Jobs
totaler Bullshit und Schwachsinn ist, dann verkürze ich einfach noch um einen Tag, fertig.
Über Probleme habe ich keine und also verdiene ich noch Geld mit YouTube und Twitch und OnlyFans,
habe ich keine Schmerzen mit und dementsprechend komme ich damit über die Runden.
Ziemlich gut, dann mache ich da weniger, weil das sehe ich in der aktuellen Zeit gar nicht
ein.
Tja, wie ist Urlaub, oh ist ganz gut, übrigens es gibt bald Channel-Memberships, es gibt bald
Channel-Memberships auf YouTube bei mir, ich habe alle Badges und Emotes am Start und ich
muss im Endeffekt nur noch ein Ankündigungsvideo und einen Community-Post machen und bald gibt
es bei YouTube auch so eine Übersicht zu so einem Membership-Dashboard oder so, wo die
sich alle gegenseitig feiern können.
Chat, ich muss euch mal fragen, bei YouTube, also jetzt mal ernsthaft, ich muss ein bisschen
ausruhen, also bei Twitch ist es ja so, wenn du subscriben willst, wenn du subscriben willst,
du hast bei Twitch eigentlich nur die Chance, du subscribst entweder mit einem Tier-1, das
kostet 4 Dollar, nicht dass ich jetzt misst erzähle, ich subscribe so selten, 4 Dollar
oder aber ich subscribe jetzt einfach mal einen von euch hier was, oder zumindest klicke
ich es an, dass ich das mal genau sehe, 3,99 Euro oder du kannst Stufe 2 Subscription machen,
7,99 oder Stufe 3, 1999, so das ist es auf Twitch, was haltet ihr denn für sinnvolle
Stufen auf YouTube, ich will da nicht so viele machen, eigentlich nur 2, am liebsten würde
ich sowas machen, oder was heißt am liebsten, am besten wäre doch sowas, wo fange ich am
besten an, ich mache 2 Stufen, ich mache 2 Stufen, also ne, ich glaube das kleinste
ist 1,99 oder so, also ich hätte gesagt 2,99 oder 3,99, also 2,99 und 3,99 Stufe 1 und
2, oder 2,99, 4,99 oder 3,99 anfangen und dann nur eine Stufe oder so, keine Ahnung,
was haltet ihr für am sinnvollsten, ich mein was man bekommt dafür ist die besten Emotes,
die wir hier auch haben, wobei es gibt noch ein paar Custom Emotes, wahrscheinlich, mal
gucken wie ich das am besten mache und es gibt extra Sub Badges, was hat ein Pewdiepie,
was hat ein Pewdiepie, wenn man subscriben will, ja, Willkongels, was hat ein Pewdiepie,
fuck, ich kann ja nicht ausprobieren, was hat der, ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung, Share,
ne ich sage der Membership, ich weiß es gar nicht, ach Join musste klicken, stimmt, Join,
ja geht auch nicht, ich weiß nicht, wie der Share ist, ehrlich gesagt, das ist eine gute
Frage, 1,99 Tier 1, 4,99 Tier 2, das finde ich ist eigentlich gar keine schlechte Idee,
ne ich glaube 2 Tier lang, Leute, ich mache das Apple Upselling, wir machen 1,99, ich
mache 1,99, da gibt es ein Emote, fertig, mehr nicht, einfach ein Emote und dann gibt
es 4,99 und da gibt es dann 8 Emotes oder so, alle meine Slots und da denken die Leute,
ok, ich kann 2 Euro ausgeben für ein Emote oder ich kann 4 Euro ausgeben für 8 Emotes,
da gebe ich doch 4 Euro aus, Big Brain, Big Brain, wenn Apple das kann, können wir das
auch, also ich, ihr habt ja da gar nichts davon, wenn man es mal genau nimmt, doch ihr
kriegt die Emotes oder 3,99, ja das kommt auf jeden Fall noch vor Weihnachten, hast du das
vom Wendler mitbekommen, ja das habe ich mitbekommen, dass der Wendler jetzt einen Onlyfans Account
hat mit seiner Frau, Freundin, weiß nicht, ob die verheiratet sind, ja, dann ein Onlyfans
Account, das hat mich auch gewundert, aber das habe ich mitbekommen und wisst ihr was
ich auch noch mitbekommen habe?
Fragt mich nicht woher, fragt mich bitte nicht woher, nicht auf den Seiten wo ihr jetzt
denkt, aber heute habe ich Google Bildersuche gemacht, das habe ich eigentlich doch verraten,
ich habe Google Bildersuche gemacht, ich habe legit nicht danach gesucht, weil warum sollte
ich danach suchen, wenn ihr jetzt gehört was gleich kommt, aber auf einmal, ich habe nach
Valorant Helden gesucht, weil ich wissen wollte was es da mittlerweile für Helden gibt, so,
Rule, wie heißt das nochmal, Rule 34, genau, Leute, irgendwann, ich ahne nichts böses,
da kommt ein Bild, obwohl ich, nee ich habe Safe Search aus, ich habe Safe Search aus,
okay, jetzt kommt ein Bild, D.Va aus Overwatch und Ryze oder so, wie spricht man die aus,
aus Valorant, die mit dem Hut auf und beide haben solche Dinger und ich frage mich, wer
auf der Welt steht auf D.Va x Ryze und mit Dicks, wer ist auf diese Idee gekommen, das
hat mich komplett, also ich weiß, dass es zu allem irgendwie Porn gibt, aber warum, wie
kommt man auf solche Ideen, also das hat mich wieder ganz, ganz stark verwirrt, OnlyFans
von Wendler ist G-Bait, ist das so, Sylvie 2020, danke schön für den Sub, ist das so,
warum ist das G-Bait, hast du reingeguckt, hast du gekauft oder was, sowas ist safe auch
im Weeb-Channel auf dem Discord, Leute, deswegen bin ich auch nicht im Weeb-Channel auf dem
Discord, also den Weeb-Channel bei mir gibt es ja nicht mehr, da war zu abgedrehtes Zeug,
ich gehe jetzt garantiert nicht auf Reddit und suche danach, ganz bestimmt nicht, im
Stream, Leute, ich mache das auch nicht Offstream, das OnlyFans vom Wendler ist mir scheiß egal,
was juckt mich das und selbst wenn der Leute G-Baitet, ganz ehrlich, dann würde ich fast
schon so weit gehen und sagen, die haben es nicht besser verdient, wer subscribt, bitte
schön, OnlyFans vom Wendler, die wollen eigentlich alle bloß seine Freundin Nagi sehen und was
auch immer sie sich da noch versprechen von, keine Ahnung, aber wer so einen Scheiß subscribt,
der muss eigentlich fast schon G-Baitet werden, mal ganz davon abgesehen, es gibt eigentlich
fast überall immer OnlyFans Leaks, also warum sollte das jemand subscriben, keine Ahnung,
juckt mich ehrlich gesagt nicht, was der treibt, aber ja, ich habe mitbekommen, dass der sowas
hat, ich habe keine Ahnung, ich habe da wirklich nicht danach geguckt, also es gibt wirklich
fast alles, interessiert mich mehr, als was der Wendler macht oder die Freundin vom Wendler,
das ist mir vollkommen egal, das ist mir so egal, dass ich noch nicht mal nach Leaks geguckt
hätte, ja, deswegen ja, irgendjemand muss noch subscriben, was ist der Unterschied zwischen
OnlyFans und Patreon, naja, OnlyFans sind eher dieser Content und Patreon der normale Content,
beziehungsweise eigentlich ist Patreon gar kein Content, meistens ist da vielleicht irgendwelche
Sub-Only Sachen verknüpft oder Early Video Access oder sowas, aber OnlyFans ist halt
eine komplette Content Plattform, wohingegen Patreon eher so ein Spenden Ding ist, was ich
ja witzig fand, dass OnlyFans eine Zeit lang aber gesagt hat so nach dem Motto, sie wollen
keinen Porn mehr erlauben und dann ist ihnen selbst eingefallen, oh fuck, unsere Plattform
ist ja bedeutungslos, ohne Porn und dann haben sie wieder zurückgerudert, jetzt wieder alles
okay.
Ja gut, Tumblr hat's verschissen, Yahoo hat Tumblr gekauft und ich weiß nicht, gibt es
irgendwas, was Yahoo gekauft hat und das gut geworden ist?
Gut, Yahoo selbst gibt es ja auch in der Form nicht mehr, keine Ahnung, ist alles RIP.
Haben die nicht großartig angekündigt Battlefield Friends Return und das ist eigentlich nur
ein Reupload von Battlefield 3 und Battlefield 4, also es gibt gar keine neuen Battlefield
Friends oder?
Wahrscheinlich wollte der neue Battlefield Friends machen und dann kam Battlefield 2042
und war einfach nur scheiße und hat sich gedacht, gut ich mach keine neuen Battlefield Friends,
ich lad einfach alles nochmal Reupload und dann ist Schluss.
Patch 4 kommt offiziell morgen, ja gucken wir uns morgen auch an.
Es wird neue Battlefield Friends geben, die haben nur angekündigt, dass sie es erst spielen
müssen, ja die haben wahrscheinlich keinen Bock mehr, das ist doch das was ich meine.
Wer konnte auch damit rechnen, dass das Game so kacke wird?
Wenn man ehrlich ist, konnte man da schon seit langer Zeit mit rechnen, wenn ich ehrlich
bin ja, aber ich wollte es auch nicht sehen am Anfang, aber spätestens seit der Beta
waren die Hinweise doch schon ziemlich groß.
Oh guck mal mein eigenes Video, wie viele Comments hatten das mittlerweile?
Oh relativ viel wohl, Dating Tipps von Max, genau weil ich da auch der Richtige für bin.
Leute mir tut der Hals weh, ich mach mich vom Acker, das war eh sehr spontane Geschichte,
die nächsten Tage machen wir wieder Aufräumen mit Max, wir machen Sonntag Stream, wir gucken
uns morgen Battlefield an, ja Zeug halt, Leute wir sehen uns, machts gut, was gibts in Battlefield,
neuer Patch, ja ich muss auch noch Steckdosenleisten flashen, das stimmt, ich hab ja noch welche,
also machts gut, danke für die Subs Leute, wen hab ich denn vergessen hier, Sylvie hat
gesubbt, Rainer hat gesubbt noch, PunktDefault hat gesubbt, MrVali, Filo, das wars, dankeschön
Leute, bis denn, machts gut, see you.